as up guys my name is Jenna wild episode
12 of the Sparky game engine series so
today we're going to be covering a
little cool thing called transformation
stacks so guys just let's just open up
the drawing board and begin where are
you so I finally updated mischief by the
way so it won't be begging me to update
it every five seconds that's good news
okay so what is a transformation stack
well basically what we want to be able
to do is say I think almost almost the
best way to equate this is probably just
to be like on best way to explain it
would be to compare it to kind of legacy
OpenGL push and pop matrix that's
probably one of the best ways to explain
it but for those of you who don't know
legacy OpenGL that's not going to help
you so I'm going to kind of explain it
from scratch basically picture this
scenario we've got five sprite all in
fact picture this scenario we've got
five sprites yeah I'm not actually going
to write them I'm going to draw them
instead in fact I wanted to draw them in
blue or teal so in what five sprites not
that closely together we've got five
sprites which we want to submit right
let's just let's just say that they're
not all circles let's just say that one
of them is for example the background of
like a menu okay maybe we've got two
menus we've got one over here one over
here okay and these are two backgrounds
for them right so what we want to do is
we want to submit this into the renderer
because we need to render these two
backgrounds so basically picture it this
way I probably not explaining this very
well this is the window this black
border and then we want to have kind of
two lists of backgrounds for example
right as in two lists of items and we
want them to have some kind of colored
background maybe ones teal and the other
ones also too so we've done that right
and now what we want to do is submit
them to the red row so they get rendered
next what we want to do though is we
want to actually have like maybe text in
each of these right so we want to have
buttons or by text or something just
drawn in each of these yeah we want to
be able to specify these things or these
these lists or the
is components relative to basically
their parent component so what we want
to do is we want to apply both the
transformation of this whether it be
rotation but just normal translation or
scale whatever yeah we want to apply the
transformation of this background to
these buttons as well so that we can
just be like I want to background to be
at 500 , live for just living in 2d
space 500 , like 100 right so maybe
that's this point up here and then I
want a button inside that to be at fifty
fifty right and what will happen is in
turn this this button here so this is
the button this is like the background
they both begin with G so I'm just going
to say I was going to say box for that
also begins with E oh man button and
background I'll just write BG in bu
right so this bu will basically have a
transformation of five hundred and fifty
comma one hundred fifty apply to it
right in terms but you specify its
position like that so the way this is
going to work is when we do something
like I'm going to for example specify
all of the components inside this what I
do is I push we have a background we
submit it to the renderer we push a
matrix which is a translation matrix
which is five hundred 100 we add all of
our buttons to the renderer and then we
pop that matrix so that we go back to
normal right so when we push it we go
from here to there when we pop it we go
from there back to here right that makes
sense so that's kind of how this whole
thing works and of course you can push
multiple times you can pop multiple
times so because we do this stuff how
it's actually going to be stored
underlying kind of under under
everything is going to be any vector of
just matrices so vector of mat force I
don't know why I wrote that in capitals
because it's not actually in capitals
but I'm a time vector of matte Falls
okay so what happens is when we push
we push since again this is another
thing that is probably worth discussion
at this point when we push one matrix so
let's just say we push this one and then
suddenly we've got a button as I said a
50/50 and inside there there might be
text at say 5 5 yeah so if we have this
kind of 1/2 and then all my goodness
there's a third kind of matrix what
should happen is this this thing
obviously has to have this and that
apply to it so it has to be five five
five one five five yeah for the for the
piece of text if it's inside here so in
order for that to work when we push we
don't simply push we don't simply push
back a a matrix into this standard
vector alright that's not what we do we
have to multiply the new matrix by the
last matrix that was in here if that
makes sense so for example so for
example a good way to do this is if we
had a push function which took in a mat
for we would basically just say and that
is terrible we would basically just say
that let's go ahead and take our vector
which is this data structure here and
then we'll push back the back of that
vector times this map form and that
would kind of be how it works so we
actually need to multiply it if we want
to push a brand new matrix to the stack
without pushing without popping
everything for it so for example we
might want to have all this upper
suddenly in the middle we're like
actually I want to push another
component it's relative to just nothing
we can do something called a push
override I don't know if we will put
that in today because it's probably not
that useful I mean it is but I think we
can live without it for now for the sake
of simplicity so that's kind of that's
kind of the idea okay
we want to be able to have that function
out and then of course when we pop pop
popping is popping as much simple much
more simple so when we pop we don't
specify MA
tricks all pop does is it literally
calls VDOT pop back and that's like it
so it'll just remove the last component
from our or the last matrix so that's
the whole transformation stack thing
okay it's not too difficult it's handled
by the renderer and of course when we go
through this we have to grab whatever oh
and one thing I should mention as well
is that this vector always has one
component because you might be like well
what if I push back like my first matrix
whatever what is V back like what's
going on so this will always have one
component and that will be the identity
matrix and by component I mean matrix so
this vector will always have one matrix
in it and they'll be identity okay
so what happens of course if nothing is
on the stack the identity matrix will be
multiplied and will be all good so now
that we've got this data structure of
matrices how do they actually affect our
components right how they actually
affect all of our renderable when they
get rendered and when they get submitted
well what happens is when we go into our
submission code right over here and this
might be easier just to show in code so
if I open up our batch render for
example we've got all these vertices
right all we have to do is just multiply
this vertex which is a vector 3 so we
don't actually have a way to multiply
Matt Ford's by vector ease yet so we
need to definitely add that into our
matrix class but what happens is for
each of these vertices that we have here
we need to basically multiply the
position or have basically the position
or I should say yeah multiplied the
position by the whatever the matrix is
so it'll be actually the other way
around so we'll multiply the matrix by
the position so if I had a matrix of
translation 5 5 for example I'd have to
multiply that with the position which
would give me my new position okay
now the other question that I assumed
any of you might actually have is why
can Badgers be vectors why can't I just
be like why do I have to push matrices
right why can't I just say you know if
all you want is this kind of translation
where you just have all this stuff and
it's relative to other stuff why not
just have a Veck vector vector ease
right and then all you'd have to do is
be like oh let's push back a vector Oh
hundred 100 right which means that if I
do fifty-fifty it will be 500 plus 50
and we'll actually get into our same
position that's totally okay and that
will work for that right it will not
work when you have things like rotation
okay if I want to rotate a component
suddenly and have things relative to
that rotation which is very very common
by the way there's no way I can do that
with position more vectors whereas of
course matrices are capable of storing
rotation same thing applies to scale
okay so that is the huge idea okay cool
so that's the general plan and yeah I
felt it was probably necessary to
explain that very thing because some
people might not understand why you
can't do that so that is why because
because we're not remembered the
transformation stack is a transformation
stack sort of some of the translation
stack right is the transformation stack
which means that it handles any kind of
transformation including rotation scale
not just translation all right cool
we're ready to begin so in case you
didn't catch up with what we had last
time we had layers which means that
basically these that pink sprite versus
the background is on two separate layers
we're running in debug mode now which is
why the performance is so terrible in
fact let's quickly cover since we're
over here let's cover a way to increase
debug performance so currently our debug
performance is not really acceptable
especially because release mode runs at
about 750
I think frames per second one quick way
that we can speed up debug mode and the
reason you want to be in debug mode by
the way is because you want to be able
to check things out so a quick example
would be something like if I put a
breakpoint here and I'm in debug mode I
get to see everything that's going on I
can see these shaders I can see these
layers I can see everything these layers
contain everything's totally okay the
size is fine everything I have is
actually properly kind of available to
me the problem is once the compiler
optimizes certain things and inlines
them and does all this crazy stuff it's
going to be harder for you to read
variables because they've changed so
much so for example you can say that our
renderable size is 416 is clearly
not correct and the reason it's done
that is because all this optimization
has occurred and it's not actually just
available for us so it's terrible for
debugging but it's beautiful for actual
release hence the name so one way we can
just speed up debugging a bit because
our debug mode is running very very
slowly right now 34 frames per second is
we can drop into properties and there is
a setting under I think let's just find
it somewhere it's here somewhere
no where is it let's just search for it
hit enable and it's here somewhere where
did it go
I'll find it don't you worry um
it's here somewhere so let's see code
owner yes basic runtime checks so it's
set on default we don't want that it
should be on uninitialized variables
okay if we do that we should run
significantly faster but why not okay
well that was fantastic we end it oh
it's clear on release so this should be
on default I should have probably it
because it should be on both by default
so let's change this back to debug and
change it from both to uninitialized
variables okay now take five all of this
it all to recompile the code obviously
with these new settings in mind it
should be quite faster okay and we
basically shouldn't have lost our
functionality so if I place a breakpoint
here we are in debug mode and we should
have the size being like proper and
everything so it should be totally okay
basically you basically penalty-free
but we we have much faster performance
okay cool so that's just a quick tip for
dealing with demo mode all right
let's let's begin with the
transformation stack so if we just go
into batch renderer really every
renderer should have this okay I'm just
going to quickly check out the simple
renderer and see how is silver under wow
that is simple it's like like 30 lines
of code
yes so it might be a bit difficult with
the simple renderer because sprites
position actually no it won't be there's
a translation and it's a model matrix
for it so yeah it'll be totally okay
good now back to our renderer so our
render now should have a protected
standard vector of vector force okay and
we'll call this M transformation stack
all right nice long name so that
everyone can understand exactly what it
is which is the plan okay
great so now that we've got that if we
dip into our oh sorry well we need to
add functions to this clearly so over
here we'll have and these don't need to
be overridden at all I'm pretty sure I
can't really think of a circumstance in
which you'd want to overwrite them so
we'll have void so push okay and I guess
we should probably just expect them to
be like we don't have to call push
matrix what's called push so we'll have
pushing pop right because they take in a
mat for so you'll be like oh and it'll
open I totally know what's going on
so we'll implement them here so all this
has to do remember is it doesn't simply
go and transformation stack they'll push
back matrix okay one thing I should
probably mention is the fact that when
we create a
so we'll make it over here we'll have a
renderer 2d we'll have a constructor so
this constructor all it will do is it
will go M transformation stack push back
map maths mat for identity alright cool
so now we've got at least one thing in
there now the reason this is this should
actually be private so the reason this
is completely private and everything is
because remember we don't want to pop
back if we're we can't pop it too many
times because if we if we keep pop
backing and we actually pop this
identity matrix things will happen and
they will not happen that there won't be
good so when we do this we want to
basically take our um our back thing
which is M transformation stack thanks
for removing matrix pro dot back right
time which is the last element so dot
back is the same thing as just filling
that all right so that is the same as
dot back so we're multiplying our last
matrix which will be identity for
example by our normal matrix and we're
pushing that result in okay very
important now that's that's push so pop
will be a bit different pop won't
obviously take in anything pop is just
supposed to pop back okay but to avoid
whoops to avoid doing this multiple
times because we do definitely we
definitely do not want to do this
multiple times we have to check to see
if transformation stacks size is greater
than 1 then we will pop back okay
because if it is 1 it means we've just
got the identity matrix in that we want
to avoid popping that ok cool
that's it you can throw some kind of
exception once we have our logging
system I'm definitely going to I'll
probably just scramble
I'll probably just scramble to dues or
everywhere because we don't have a
logging system yet the reason I'm not
really concerned about that too much
I'll hopefully get it in before all of
them there but the reason I'm not
concerned with it too much is just
because it's not really cutting edge
feature it's more of a debug feature
obviously it's not something that we
actually need it's something that will
help us develop so that's why it's not a
high priority feature especially you
guys are going to have to get used to
that stuff that is good for developers
but not for the customers or the I
should probably say since this is going
to be free obviously this game I should
say the user base or whoever placed all
all the players stuff that is useful to
developers with non players the players
will obviously have a higher priority so
that's an important thing to note but
that is the idea
push and pop cool that is done if we
wanted to have push override we might as
well put that in there so we'll have a
push override okay so a push override in
fact I might just do this I'll have a
push and then we'll have a ball
override equals false by default okay
one thing you can do in C++ and you
can't do this in Java you can do this in
c-sharp but one thing we can do is we
can specify defaults to variables as
long as they're on the end so if it's
the last parameter you can specify
default for it which means that right
now this is equivalent to me having two
of the same function and one the taste
in one parameter one that takes in two
so by doing this I'm basically allowing
people to just use push with just
specifying a matrix and that's it no
second parameter and if you don't
specify second parameter it will be
assumed to be false okay that's useful
because what I want to do is if override
I want to so we'll have an else okay so
if it's not overridden I want to do this
if it is override I basically want to do
the same thing except I don't want to
multiply it okay so that's the idea
all right so if if we and again as I
said the reason we might want to do this
is because we want to get back to our
identity basically but we do not want to
pop everything off we just want to push
this one do something real and then pop
it okay cool
right that looks pretty good so that's
pretty much the extent of our actual
kind of handling of our transformation
stack and how it kind of works behind
the scenes and how push and pull work
okay
now to actually implement it the thing
that has to implement it is the actual
renderer okay because every renderer
does things uniquely it is important for
the actual renderer to implement this
stuff itself okay so you can't just
generally be like oh cool I'll implement
it and everything will work no the
actual flash or usually submit will
actually have to use that transformation
stack to transform its vertices so what
I can do or what I have to do now in
batch render are the C++ one please ah
is in our submit which is what does all
this fun stuff we need to go ahead and
basically grab the current matrix from
our our stack of matrices okay so the
back one and multiply it with the
position and that will give us the
vertex so basically just to show you an
example is we have to go mmm
transformation stack oh I made a private
let's go back yeah I should have made
private it should be private in the
sense that nothing should modify it
except for this but we obviously need
access to it before in here so we'll
make it protected all right um note I'm
still giving this protective here
because that's actually like a method I
like to collect a separate variables and
methods by something like this so there
you go all right cool it's just like a
little kind of code style convention
thing okay so we want to grab em
transformation stack that is not what I
wanted at all Visual Studio dot back
okay and multiply it with position this
should give us a
back three okay right now it's invalid
because you can't multiply matrices with
back threes but we'll fear that out so
let's quickly cover how that's going to
work this whole multiplying with vector
three is how is month at four versus of
every three what's going on so one thing
that you would know if you went to
school and learned about matrix maths
just in general not in graphics
programming is you can multiply if we've
got a four by four matrix
yeah we can multiply it with something
like a four by one okay as long as these
two numbers are the same you can
multiply it okay we don't really care
about these too much but these two have
to be the same so if this is say rows
and columns then it has to be multiplied
all about against this now clearly we do
it a bit differently we do column major
so we'll have columns and rows columns
and rows so the rows of this yeah so if
we have a four by four matrix the rows
of the matrix which is this part has to
be the same as the column count so the
number of components has to be the same
okay it is because we've got a four by
four matrix so clearly we do have a row
that has four components and we've got a
vector four for example which has this
now can we do it against a three no we
can't we can't do that that you can't
actually multiply four by four matrix
with a 3 by 1 matrix or just a three
component vector you can do it with a
four now since we've got a three all we
have to do is basically not change the
last component so we assumed the last
component to just be one so if we have
our if we have an actual vector a vac
three would look like something like
this right but we add a fourth component
where it has one that way we multiply
one with it and everything is the best
now is it worth converting a vector into
effect for no that is not a good idea in
terms of performance so we we want to
basically that this is just kind of the
behind-the-scenes I'm assuming this is
how it works kind of thing just so you
guys know how it works okay all we're
going to do is
and I'm not assuming this is our voice
this is how it works
but what I should say is this is just
something to let you guys know how it's
actually going to work but the idea is
when we do this we basically and the way
the matrix multiplication works everyone
should know this by the way I've covered
this a million times in other videos and
if you dumb maths you would know this we
basically take the row and we multiply
it with the column so we take each row
and multiply with the column that's how
it gives us the answer so a four by four
times so if we had this right and we had
a b c d i should do this in column major
though a b c d e f g h i j k l m n o P
times X Y Z 1 okay that will give us a
vac 4 okay
so what will happen is we will multiply
each column by it well we'll multiply
each row by each column because we can't
data on columns here there aren't rows
here each row and then that multiplied
by that will give us our first answer
okay so that's the idea so basically two
because we're about to write this but I
want you guys to understand it is a
times X plus C times y plus I times Z
right you guys are getting the pattern
plus M times 1 plus M times 1 is going
to equal our first answer so I'm just
going to write a 1 that's a 1 right
that's how it's going to do it now the
second thing is going to be the same
it's going to be B times X plus F times
y et cetera
right and that will give us a 2 and then
so on and so forth to give us these
three things now since we don't have 1/4
components and we're just dealing with
this the fourth component will still
kind of exist but we're doing two things
a we're not returning the foot the
fourth component but we still need
to do something with this fourth row so
we just say we just imagine that fourth
row is essentially just one okay so the
idea kind of is just that we we
basically just add on that fourth row
instead of multiplying it with something
okay and you guys will see that when we
actually implemented so that's it that's
how simple this thing is so if we go
into Matt four because we need to
include this stuff in our Matt for what
we want to do is we want to add and you
can call this whatever you want I'm just
going to basically make it a
multiplication operator which returns
our back three so it's going to be a
vector II operator multiple care thing
which will take in a matte four and a
vac three okay so it's ah yes
and we're taking let's change it around
a little bit because right now it's
taking in them at four
it's going to return so this is going to
probably return let's see so this is
going to return back three it's going to
take in left
and it's definitely not going to modify
that either so how do we have this set
up let me quickly just check left mult
so we added up multiplied oh I see the
problem was it returned
yeah returned this that's why we had it
set up like this so because of that fact
let's just rewrite it as this will
return a vector three it won't be a yep
I should say it won't be a it won't be
returning a reference clearly because
it's returning a completely different
class which probably brought this down
as well but it will take in it we know
that the map for is our current one so
it'll just be the other one okay so with
vac three it will kind of work the same
except of course we aren't multiplying
left versus right anymore we return
something brand-new so we definitely
should be passing this by reference but
there we go that's kind of the idea and
we will not have a x equals because
clearly our result using a matte four so
that's our transformation got it back
three multiplies that four multiplies
will work the same way in fact I'm
thinking we might as well just add that
in right now because it might it'll be
useful in the future and since we're on
this topic it would be totally ok all
right cool so there we go we've got a
bunch of methods to implement now let's
go ahead and implement them so we'll
deal with the multipliers first I'll
probably deal with a vector for multiply
first because that will that's kind of
what effect three months play is except
with the thing but if we go into Matt
four because I multiply okay so back
four
okay so this is going to multiply the
current matrix by this but it's going to
read it's not going to affect the
current matrix clearly one thing I
should probably note is these definitely
should be Const
okay they shouldn't be affecting that
what if that is cons but it shouldn't be
affecting the actual matrix at all okay
it should be on it should be just just
be creating a a new deck for okay so
basically we can just kind of return
this as a vet for like this we don't
have to actually create a foothold
result and then we can do each row here
so as I covered over here we need to
multiply each column by each sorry each
row by each column and then add it as an
answer over here so to do that we've got
a few options we've got two ways of
accessing currently we can either do it
by columns or by elements I want to use
columns that probably be a bit more
simple than elements because with
elements we'll have to do something like
elements zero and then the next one will
be elements for instance we're going
across the row right so it might be
better just to say call um let's see so
columns dot columns zero so that'll be
the first column 2x times other dot X
all right that's right
plus columns one dot X right times y
plus whoa too far
Plus columns 2x plus other than Z plus
columns 3x okay and that is our first
one all right
that is our very there we go that is our
very first one so for the others it's
going to be very simple this is just my
goodness my hands are just slopping all
over the place all over this keyboard
this will just go ahead and be changed
into what No
sorry I meant to do this and also if I
said twice ah
everything is just all over the place um
why is there w-why does insert delete
two characters what were you doing that
there why is there w WS and y MW w w w
whoo all right there we go
so this is still mad um because I forgot
the calmest
okay there we go so that is the plan it
looks pretty good yeah it looks
fantastic
all right cool so the vac three
multiplied will be basically the same
whoa
excuse me what the vac three multiplied
will basically be the same except over
they won't have that last one and what's
important to note is apart from not
having that last one it will simply just
not have this other W since other del W
is a three okay that's really the only
difference so we can just basically
delete that all right that's it that's
our entire master plan okay there we go
so that's the idea we now need to
implement the overloaded operators so if
we go down to our friends
which are right another knot yes they
are these are at the at the other end so
we'll go ahead and they should be under
we'll go ahead and just implement that
so we had a fact three and we had a
effect for that I just kill two birds
with one stone and just implement both
of them straight away again we don't
really need the back for yet but we will
okay so left on to file right and
everything was good in the hood except
for these so let's go back here quickly
and just copy these all right cool
there we go so that's looking pretty
good um yeah we're basically done okay
cool so now that we've got this we can
go back into our simple render ah sorry
our bat renderer and this should now not
be a problem but it is and this is what
is a victory
so no meshes somebody maths ah okay one
thing I should do is I should get the
batch render are also I should get the
renderer to have Const matrices where
where where is
yeah we don't weather all we want
references is another unit is another
problem we don't really want references
because yeah we don't really want
references so we probably do want this
to take in a Const reference but when we
push back it's not going to be pushing
back a reference okay that's an
important note as well because we don't
we we kind of do want to copy it as well
so that's another important thing to
mention now this is still sad so why is
it still sad that's a vector e reference
that's a that's yeah that's going to be
a map for and yet we're still we're
still very sad that's a bit weird let's
just try it out multiply and see where
the problem lies
so that's fine so what's wrong with our
operator mm suspicious very suspicious
hmm so constant for reference left it
shouldn't matter that should work
weird let's try the next one
with the dot well
um so now it's working
so what's position position is a Const
reference interesting so let's float
back here oh it's not Const whoops and
here it was okay that was my mistake I
even did declare it Const here well okay
so now it should work yeah okay so there
we go
let's just change this to take this
stuff in and there we go all right cool
so now we're multiplying everything with
the back of the transformation stack
let's just run this and see if it works
properly till we should get the same
result right now because we're not doing
anything yeah looks pretty good except
the performance is now terrible this
will this will hit this will affect
performance by the way it shouldn't have
affected performance that much though
that is suspicious hmm
let's quickly switch into it to release
and see what it's like oh yeah that just
decimated our performance though so it's
fine and release
well I guess we'll be mostly in release
mode from now on I mean we don't need to
be drawing we don't need to be
continually drawing 50,000 sprites so
I'm going to just say if oh yeah okay so
we can do up to my sessions to this as
well but what we'll do is we'll just say
if test 50 K we'll just do that so you
probably see a sprites
and
okay
okay so now when I'll doing that let's
add what well I mean I do want to do
something similarly to this let's let's
just add like not as much basically
because I still want to have a bunch of
sprites just not probably not quite as
much we just don't need that much
so 0.9 there we go so that should be a
good amount surprise and it shouldn't be
too bad either okay cool
so yeah um 5000 FPS all right one thing
I want to do quickly before we move on
is I could okay
we'll do a quick up the optimization now
to get it a bit to get to run a bit
better but if I just I guess I'll just
put an else oops
lull alright so if we are testing the
50,000 sprites you can probably see that
in debug mode our performance is very
bad it is like 10 FPS which is terrible
one way we could improve this is by so
this back operator is suspiciously bad
so what we could do is we could just
catch the result of this so every time
we push let's quickly where's our let's
just close some of these things I get so
confused when looking so many open
things we could basically catch this so
we could be like maths Matt for we could
just make this a Const reference as well
we could just call this M transformation
back right yeah we probably have to I'm
just going to make it a pointer
we'll say that every time wait so in
this case we'll set it equal to alright
there we go so we've got there we go
we've got that now why you mad you're
mad okay so and then every time we we do
all this pushing and popping we just
need to update it all right there we go
and then we should have that slog okay
so there we go so we updated every time
we push and pop it and that way when we
go into our bash renderer we don't have
to do this anymore we can just go em
transformation back dereference that and
this should hopefully make it a bit
faster
mm right now remember what is doing
identity yeah so you can see how much
faster it is now just by not using the
vectors back operator okay so that's
something that you should all remember
okay cool
so anyway we're submitting all these
sprites where we so many other in layers
now aren't they so let's go ahead and
just for fun let's go into our layer so
it's a tile layer and I don't know we'll
just go renderer this will be probably
best done in so this is where it gets a
bit annoying it's good with groups and
whatnot but we'll probably go ahead and
say over here when we're submitting all
these so right now we'll just try it out
and we'll say something like um renderer
dot or arrow push let's just do a
translation of like five so
all right so we're pushing this and I
guess we can probably pop it like here
now well we need to flash it fit no we
don't reach this minute yeah pop it here
see if it was the other renderer we
probably would need to actually we
probably would need to actually wait to
flash first but okay so that seemed to
worked now let's try it for varying
sprites so I can just go into Michael's
here so we'll do it for every second
sprite so we'll go ahead and say you
know submission here that will just say
I plus plus or in fact we can just say
if I mod two equals zero then let's
probably over in this cup as well will
do that will submit all due at 5:00 and
then for the other one on fat I can just
do five zero zero five this is look
weird
this will definitely look weird but it's
a good way to test I don't know if this
is working so if we test something like
this out apart from performing quite
terribly now because we are changing
each and every sprite you should see the
awesomeness of the translation what not
it doesn't seem to be affecting
everything that I say we did let's so it
was any but I've what if we do I that
would be really dangerous I'm not really
we'll just probably lose motion
off-screen yep they're all gone okay so
ah
anyway where's my lair where's my there
is um anyway ah that should pretty much
be the case okay so there's our
transformation stack we can do it a much
better way of so unfortunately the other
thing right now that we have to do is
basically have it in almost purse bright
because of the fact that it's in because
of the fact that it is in the lair so if
we wanted we could probably do something
like this but let's actually try and do
something kind of real world and see it
work for that so if we turn that off so
let's just say I have a button
I have a button that just happens to be
at so well we'll just we'll pretend
we're making some kind of GUI and we've
got a button at like 2 that'll be the
middle one so - like 15 we'll have it at
like 8 it'll be 2 by 1 and the color
will just be like white white I tell
something I don't know
all right so if we take a look at this
okay there it is so the Lighting's being
a bit mine but was that was there other
let's not run to later okay so I should
have said 7
all right so there's our button it's
supposed to be white but it's not
because it's lighting so we could let's
just say we wanted to add something into
it so it's a bit small right now let's
just make it 4-2 or something that's
still a bit small six three I'll drop it
to like here okay so there's our button
okay with let me just change the
lighting to work a bit better so that'll
be a quicker way to do it or not this is
our normal shader
we using a normal shader for that aren't
we yep my lighting my lighting is just
not working with me today um there we go
so we've got this um let's just set a
these videos are just so long I don't
mind them being long it's just they take
forever to render anyway let's say we
add a we want to have a button on
another legend a pink like component
inside that thing so what I would like
to do is say something like I want it to
be at 0.2 0.2 with length of so out with
an artistic and 3 so we'll make it like
that I want to say 0.5
we'll make it like 5.5 or something I've
just 5.0 basically and then for this
we'll just make it
2.0 so I want this one to be inside this
one okay and I wanted to be pink that's
our plan right now obviously so I'm
going to work going to put this one here
I wanted to be inside this though so how
can we do something like that well what
we want to do basically is the usage of
this is we kind of want to be like
layered I'll push a matrix so a matrix
that is basically if we make us right
we want a matrix that is made up from
this position we want to push that right
and then at the end we basically want to
pop it okay this is where it becomes a
bit complicated because we want to
basically say that do we want sprites to
be tied with this well no because we
just want a bunch of things to be tied
with this and it becomes a bit
complicated because we need to know what
matrices are like essentially
apply to what thing what do are things
so let's say if we go to well okay yeah
so if we go to layer well what we kind
of want it to do is for each renderable
we want to kind of basically see what
the all it does right now is it just it
submits the the writer of all to
actually be rendered okay but it doesn't
actually access the the transformation
stack of the renderer so what it should
do is it should check out which
renderable is doing at the stack to that
well not and it should basically act
that way so the problem we have here is
how do we get it to be relative to that
without because something because
basically when we're submitting this we
do want to be using push and pop based
on what we're doing but it kind of
becomes a bit impossible with this whole
let's just rather than all at once kind
of thing okay that is where groups are
going to come in okay so fear not that
will be the whole scenario of groups
which we're going to cover next episode
all right
so if you guys enjoyed this episode
please hit the like button and I'll see
you next time goodbye
Oh